hey guys today we're gonna talk about
anti nutrients in vegetables and other
foods plants don't like to be eaten
they've developed certain defense
mechanisms to help them survive over
millions of years because they can't run
away and this is to prevent the insects
and other predators from consuming them
okay so let's start off with
phytoestrogens okay so certain plants
like flax and soy have these little
chemical compounds called vital essence
and they can actually create a little
bit of a birth control effect in insects
so for the purpose of surviving because
if you can make sterile all these
insects and they won't reproduce the
plant survives so that's an ingenious
strategy but the problem that I see is
not the phytoestrogens that you're going
to buy from the health food store that
are good for hot flashes or other health
conditions but the type of soy oil in
soy protein isolates that are put out in
certain veggie burgers and also even put
in baby formulas we don't know the
long-term effects also the massive
amount of soy oil which is mostly
genetically modified in your salad
dressings in your foods we don't know of
the long-term effects of that all right
moving along to phytic acid phytic acid
is another chemical that is an anti
nutrient it prevents the absorption of
many minerals including zinc iron
calcium things like that now it is in
seeds and nuts and it's actually in the
brand part now the thing about phytic
acid is that some people take it for
health benefits let's say for example
you have excessive amounts of iron in
your body which is common with men
because men and women don't have the
ability to get rid of excessive iron
women do on their cycle but men don't so
when you build up iron it creates a lot
of problems with your heart and the
damaging effect of it being an oxidant
on your body
alright so phytic acid named ip6 you can
look that up and I actually did a video
on that
has the property of being a key later it
binds with certain minerals specifically
I am so if you have high amounts of iron
it will pull it out it also has
anti-cancer benefits and there's other
other benefits as well so a lot of these
compounds have pluses and negatives
let's move on to lectins lectins are
certain proteins in plants and they're
used as a protective mechanism because
what they'll do is they'll break down
certain parts of our digestive tract and
they will put holes in our gut lining
and create leaky gut that's a simple
version there are nightshades white
potato soy brown rice grains now I
actually have a link of all the lectin
foods rated from high to low put that
down in the description but the problem
with lectins is that certain people are
sensitive to them and it can aggravate
inflammation in the body so if you have
an autoimmune condition you should be
avoiding lectins but the vast majority
of people do not have a problem with
lectins but for example gluten is a
lectin and that's in grains all right
now we have ox lids oxalates are
chemical compounds and by the way our
body makes them as well but they also
come from foods that combined with
calcium and create crystals and create a
lot of problems with kidney stones and
even inflammation and arthritis it can
accumulate in different parts of the
body the highest amount of oxalates
isn't parsley then spinach peanuts
almonds chocolate and I put a list down
below if you want a rating list of all
the foods high in oxalates then we have
subpoenas which basically it's a it's
like a detergent that will dissolve a
cell membrane and it's another
protective mechanism in certain plants
like the nightshades
it's in legumes amaranth buckwheat so as
you can see there's a lot of anti
nutrients in the food that we eat
there's also I don't even mention this
but there's some enzyme inhibitors that
block the enzyme to help break down
protein you should germinate like the
seeds and the nuts soak them in water
overnight
this is why older cultures and probably
your grandparents pickled the foods and
fermented foods to decrease the anti
nutrients in increase the nutrient
availability of certain foods so there's
a couple things you can do number one if
you don't have any problem consuming
vegetables and these foods then eat them
but if you start bloating you may have a
condition called SIBO which is small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth but to
explain SIBO in a thumbnail sketch it's
basically a situation where you have the
good bacteria that normally should be in
the large intestine now in the small
intestine so when you're eating the
vegetables and you're having the fiber
go in it's fermenting in a different
place and you're getting a lot of gas
and bloating a couple things you can do
if you actually have this condition you
can just cut out your vegetables for a
month increase acidifier for the stomach
take certain herbal antibiotics like
garlic and thyme and oregano and that
will help to eliminate that and also do
in a minute fasting but you may just
need to change the vegetables you're
consuming maybe you switch your
vegetables from cruciferous vegetables
which a lot of people are sensitive to -
more leafy greens for example I can do
leafy greens in large amounts but I
can't do broccoli for example but it
really depends on an individual when you
steamed or cooked cruciferous vegetables
they're easier to digest and they also
recommend rotating the form of
vegetables that you're consuming for
example some days I will consume just
green salad okay other days I will
consume pickle the vegetables without
any green salad at the farmers market I
found a great source of pickled
vegetables and without any sugar always
make sure it doesn't have the sugar in
there and I actually my system does very
very well on these so I will do like
maybe three or four cups of pickled
vegetables per day for a while and then
I'll go back to my leafy greens and then
I'll rotate to something else now if you
have an autoimmune condition or some
type of arthritis I would eliminate
lectins and see if you do better okay
now if you have kidney stones
I would eliminate oxalates but the cool
thing about the ketogenic diet is you're
eliminating beans grains rice potato so
you already eliminated a lot of the anti
nutrients just by doing that anyway
thanks for watching and I put some links
down below for specific information
about each one of these
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it